(swooshing)
- Hello Believe nation,
I'm Evan Carmichael,
my one word is believe and
I believe that entrepreneurs
will solve all the major
problems of the world.
And so to help you on your journey today,
I'm going to talk about
the seven must-watch
TV shows for entrepreneurs.
♫ Nine, eight
(techno music)
(hip hop beat)
Number one for me is The Profit.
It's a show put on by
CNBC with Marcus Lemonis.
Marcus is an angel investor and he goes in
and he invests his own money
into failing businesses
and tries to turn them around.
It's part entertainment and part education
and he also breaks things down in really
easy to understand ways
so that even if you're
just getting started as an entrepreneur,
or you may not have a
total comprehension of
finances and balance sheets
and income statements
and all that stuff, he makes
it easy for you to understand
and so it's a must-watch,
number one most important one
that I think entrepreneurs
need to pay attention to.
(hip hop beat)
Number two for me is Silicon Valley.
This is more of a comedy show.
It's loosely based around things
that happen in Silicon Valley.
It's meant as a spoof on the businesses
and the entrepreneurs and the investors
that are all down there kind of
in their own different world.
It's extra funny for
me because I used to be
a venture capitalist and so I come
from that world a little
bit and understand it.
I think if you are not
from the world as much or
you might be English as a second language
or you may not have the context,
it may not be a great show for you.
Nina, as an example,
doesn't like the show,
so I have to watch it by myself. Sadness.
But if you want to
learn a little bit about
the venture capital
community and have some fun
laughing at it, Silicon
Valley is worth checking out.
(hip hop beat)
Number three is Billions,
this is a pretty new show
that came out, I think they're
in Season Two right now.
I love watching this show.
It's another one where Nina
won't watch it with me.
I think some of the language
can be really fast as well
and hard to keep up with
and if you don't really know
the stock market and how
the rules kind of work
and the players there, it may
not be interesting for you,
but it's basically about
this guy who's a billionaire
who manipulates stock
markets to his own benefit
and this district attorney
who's always trying to
catch him and beat him
and send him to jail
and the fights that they go through,
webs they try to leave for each other
and traps that they put each other into.
I really like this show,
and I think it's worth checking out.
(hip hop beat)
- Dude, we totally hacked in!
Alright, go now before Evan finds out.
Hey guys, it's Marcus here
from Affiliate Marketing Dude.
And today I'm bringing you
the fourth best show on TV
to watch if you are an entrepreneur.
And as you could tell by now I've hacked
into this presentation
to show you Mr. Robot.
Mr. Robot is a great show that talks about
entrepreneurship, life, mental issues
and all kinds of things like that.
And the reason I chose
it, first and foremost,
is because of the mental struggle
that Elliot goes through.
He's a guy, he's a computer
hacker and he's going through
this mental struggle constantly
to get the things done
that he wants to do.
And one of the quotes that I like
from this very quotable
show is by Elliot himself.
He says, "Sometimes I
dream of saving the world.
Saving everybody from the invisible hand,
the one that brands us
with an employee badge.
The one that forces us to work for them.
The one that controls us every
day without us knowing it.
But I can't stop it. I'm not that special.
I'm anonymous. I'm just alone."
Now this is a struggle that
entrepreneurs have all the time.
Feeling like what they do isn't
going to make a difference.
But one of the quotes
I have on my desk here
in my office is something I
came up with years ago that says
"From this desk I can reach the world".
And in today's day and
age with technology,
as an entrepreneur most of the struggle
you are going to have is a mental struggle
whether you do something
or don't do something.
And it's the struggle of decisions.
And this show is ripe
with examples of deciding
and the mental struggle and
how businesses can go bad
and how businesses can go
good and what you can do
as an individual to make a difference.
Another quote that I like
from Mr. Robot talks about
the life of hacking and
how a computer works.
This also goes into the
mindset of the entrepreneur.
The quote is, "There's a saying,
'The devil is at his strongest when we're
looking the other way.'
Like a program running in
the background silently.
While we're busy doing other stuff."
How many programs do you have saying
I can't, I won't, I'm not good enough,
I don't have enough money,
I'm not strong enough?
And these things limit us.
They're like a program running
in the back of our brain
as if it's been hacked by
society and by life in general
and by our experiences, trying to stop us
from doing what we want to do.
And I think a big point
that this show points out
is that those background
processes, those thoughts
that have been implanted in our brain,
we don't have to listen to 'em.
We can change the world
one step at a time.
Do what we were born to do
and be the entrepreneur
we've dreamed of being.
Marcus from Affiliate
Marketing Dude, over and out.
Back to you, Evan.
(hip hop beat)
Number five is Shark Tank,
you guys probably are familiar
with it, a super hit TV show.
And what I'm really grateful
for 'cause it helped put
entrepreneurship on the map.
It's fun to tune in and watch
some of the ideas that are
pitched, sometimes they're
crazy and you laugh at them,
sometimes you tune in just
to see the Sharks fighting
with each other and
the drama that happens.
But for me I really like to see
how these successful
investors break down a deal,
what they look for, how
they negotiate the deals,
what the counters are
for the entrepreneurs,
and seeing the pitches I
think is really good business
education as well as providing
some entertainment value too.
So if you haven't already seen it,
I don't know what rock you're living under
but it's definitely worth checking out.
(hip hop beat)
Number six is Suits.
This is a fun show that's actually
filmed here in Toronto, woo N-city!
It's about a law firm, it's
about these Harvard Law
students and one of the
lawyers, super successful,
is the killer, always wins and
always has a ton of attitude
and confidence and ego and
bravado and the new upstart guy
doesn't have as much confidence but
also has a lot of heart and caring
and he wants to fight for the little guy
and his boss doesn't
really see it all the time.
There's a lot of fun
banter in between them
and a lot of movie references
and pop culture references
that you may understand or
may slide under the radar
but it's a good show to kind
of, I like it because you see
business people doing their thing,
having confidence and bravado
and winning in their arena
and so it's worth checking
out Season One at least.
I loved Season One, it was amazing.
As it got on, I think they're
in Season six or seven now,
the in-between seasons felt
like they went a little too
heavy on the drama for me,
too much drama happening in each episode
but then they kind of brought it back
to this last season I'm
really enjoying again so
watch Season One and see if you like it.
If you do, it's worth continuing on.
(hip hop beat)
And number seven is Planet of the Apps.
This is a yet to be released show.
I heard about it from Gary Vanyerchuk.
It's him, Gwyneth Paltrow,
will.i.am, and Jessica Alba
and they are basically judging people
who are pitching the apps so
people have to go on
this escalator ride down
and while they're on the
escalator they have to
pitch their idea and one of
the four judges has to say
I like you and then the
judges pick a winner
and they personally work with that person
to help them build their app
and there's some competition
to see who ends up winning
from all the apps and the coaching
with the experts on there.
So it hasn't come out,
I've only seen the trailer
but there's some interesting people on it
and I'm looking forward to
seeing the show come out
and anything that's
supporting entrepreneurship
generally I'm a pretty big fan of.
So that's my take on the seven
must-watch shows for entrepreneurs.
I'd love to know, what did you guys think?
Have you watched all seven of these?
Do you have a favorite?
Did I miss an eight, nine, 10
that you want to add to the list?
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm super curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Kevin Fiedler
from kevinfiedler.de,
thank you so much Kevin
for picking up a copy of
my book, Your One Word
and making the animated
review on it as well.
I'm so glad you loved it
and I really appreciate the support.
So thank you guys again for
watching, I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see ya soon.
(swooshing)